Americans are cursing today more
than ever before.
In fact, the average American utters
80 to 90 curse words every day.
That's about five curse
words every waking hour.
And it might not be in vain.
Turns out swearing may help you
live a healthier, happier
life in the long run.
When you stub your toe
and holler your favor
dirty, four-letter word;
you're actually doing yourself a favor.
Swearing has been known
to raise your heart rate,
which can help reduce the pain.
For example, one study found that people
who held their hand in icy water
while cursing lasted 50% longer
than people who used
neutral words like "wooden."
And "flat."
And if you're still not convinced
that you should curse more, consider this.
Swearing could be the key
to improving workouts.
Researchers asked people to curse
while riding a stationary
bike and holding a device
that measured handgrip strength.
Turns out participants pedaled
faster and gripped stronger
while spewing their favorite expletives.
And swearing won't just
help you get more fit;
it can also reduce stress and anxiety.
One study found that swearing
helped drivers better cope
with their frustration on the road
whenever a pedestrian
illegally crossed the street.
And, in fact, this kind
of emotional relief
is so common, it has a name: lalochezia.
Scientists think that
this relief is one reason
why we've evolved to
curse in the first place
because it's a way for us
to express strong emotions
like anger and frustration without having
to throw a punch or act out.
And this method of choosing words
over violence has other benefits, too.
Studies show that people
who curse are perceived
as more genuine and sincere.
And researchers have found that people
who can list the most swear
words also come across
as more honest when they're
measured on a lie scale.
But there's still one place
where cursing is almost always
out of the question: work.
But you might have a good
excuse to swear there, too.
Hey, what the (beeping)!
Researchers studied a team of workers
at a soap factory in
New Zealand, and looked
at the use of one particular swear word.
Um...
It starts with an F.
It ends with a K.
I think you know which word.
Turns out that using the
"f-word" helped workers
express politeness, alleviate tension,
and bond with each other.
But we're not saying you should
go and curse out your boss.
Although a little swearing
here and there can't hurt.
I mean (bleeping) it might even help.